and is a video of these two twin
brothers making out why holy
why what the why
forgot why
why
capital h h w h
for what in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast
listen once again this is another okay
if you're a first time listener just
know that this is solo dolo usually we
have a guest but I am in the process of
moving right now I am in the process of
of of of getting rid of old [__] uh
switching over to the new studio after
this this is actually the last time that
I'm going to be doing a podcast in this
space but uh so long farewell to this
spot
um I've been making a lot of big boy
moves lately as uh someone who is
married and in a relationship
um last time I did the solo dolo podcast
a lot of people appreciated it they said
it kind of had like the Vintage David So
Vibes
um but I I only do this in a bird
because I actually enjoy doing the
podcast with people like I love talking
to my friends I love hearing them joke
around I love you know us having
differing opinions I love going back and
forth with somebody and so you know
talking into a camera by myself has
become very very awkward but you know
your boy getting that practicing again
and we're starting up this conversation
because I don't want to leave you
hanging not having a podcast on Sunday I
get a lot of messages where people say
like yo I listened to your podcast when
I work whenever I work out uh I'm I'm in
a truck most of the time I'm doing
deliveries I'm in the restaurant I'm
cooking or I'm cleaning or I'm doing
some type of [__] and I listen to
your podcast whenever I you know need to
laugh or I need to focus on something
that I'm doing so I'm continue this if I
can't get it out most of the times I'll
be scrambling to get a guest on but
right now I am literally moving
everything into the new place so don't
have time for that hey but before we
start this podcast let me just say this
real quick and I wanted to say this
topic for uh a guest that was going to
come on because I wanted to hear their
opinion about it but I'm just going to
maybe we'll we'll do it again with um
somebody else so anyways let's just get
into the podcast today look you know
every now and then a couple of my
friends will send me some [__] that
either it's made to make me laugh or
it's there to horrify you so if you so
ladies if you don't know guys usually
have texts or group threads where they
just be setting each other [__]
disgusting and stupid memes I feel like
with Mariel they'll send each other
memes about oh did you see this thing
about BTS did you see this cute kitten
acting extra cute guys send each other
dick pics and I don't know why but we
I get a text from Timothy
and he's like did you see this island
boy thing and I'm like Island Boy what
is this island boy thing you talking
Island Boy
I'm just trying to make it I weigh 120
pounds and I'm
5'2 them boys
and let me tell you something about them
island boys before we even get into this
those boys and I've said this before a
million times looked like two heroin
needles that came to life in a Pixar
movie they are [__] up looking demons
like if I was like if I was on the verge
of death and I knew that I was going to
hell an island boy would pop up right
before me saying oh we're taking you
there they are hideous not only because
of their personality the stuff that they
do however they behave they acting like
they're [__] thugs they gonna take
you out even though they those two
probably are little [__] right and
they might even see this video they're
like well if the next time I see you
better keep that same energy well I will
and guess what if you step up to me I'ma
spray holy water on your ass and watch
you fizzle away you [__] demon you
look like you came out the coochie of a
kraken I don't want to talk to you but
Tim sends me this [__] video right
he's like have you seen this island boy
thing and I'm like what is it what is
this [__] Isla boy thing
and it is a video of these two twin
brothers making out why holy
why what the why
forgot why
why
capital h h w h
for what purpose would you do this why
I've never incest disgusting listen
I had to process this when I saw the
video I looked at it I screamed
through it through my phone
through my [__] phone
out of my car
picked it up an hour and a half later
look at the video again smashed it on
the floor I could never I don't unders
listen
this is what happens when you become a
quote unquote content creator and you
have nothing to show for your work
besides [__] Island Boy
tattooed up looks like a [__]
Etch-a-Sketch drawing all over their
[__] bodies ugly ass tattoos weird
ass looking faces with this island boy
Jamaican accent
doing [__] and people and they kind
of popped off because everybody was
making fun of them it was hilarious it
was very entertaining well guess what
after you do that move you have to
continue to make new product to bring
people in and turns out and listen I'm
not saying that you know after they
brought that song out whether it was
catchy or not they didn't have a couple
of other songs where other people are
watching it but they see these numbers
dwindle and what do they do with their
money they took their money they iced
out their [__] Grill they got the
[__] chain going on I'm pretty sure
they spent all that money on other
[__] and guess what happens to a
bunch of young people who are so [__]
in the head that they would do
absolutely anything to get those [__]
views up
he would tongue his twin brother
tongue his twin brother for [__]
views I dare run to you if there were no
cameras around if nobody was watching
them if nobody gave an actual flying
[__] about them those two would not be
tongue wrestling the [__] out of each
other in front of a camera oh David
it's 2023
let let Gay love happen them boys ain't
gay clout chasing [__]
It's the weird thing right because you
know obviously this wasn't the majority
of the comments but I saw some somebody
wrote like love is love incest
oh is this where we draw on the line now
listen if you want to be a young content
creator right obviously you're gonna
have to do something that'll get you to
pop off but if the basis of the stuff
that you're doing is simply based on
shock Factor you have to keep that up
for the rest of your two-year career and
I say two-year career because most
people who do that stuff they don't last
a very long time there are a few people
who have but a majority of people don't
especially the way that shorts and tick
tocks are made how many times have you
followed somebody on Tick Tock where
they'll get two million views three
million four million views even on
shorts in their next videos one thousand
two thousand three thousand four hundred
the shock Factor's done nobody gives a
[__] it's like the same thing with
celebrity boxing how excited were we to
see Jake Paul box even though we were
talking [__] we were saying all this
stuff we still tuned in and we watched
that [__] because it was a freak Show
we come in to watch the freak Show but
when the freak Show stops delivering and
we get desensitized because we've seen
the same trick over and over and over
again we don't give a [__] that's the
same thing with these [__] island
boys right the shock Factor's over okay
you guys are two [__] weirdos that
are I don't know when the when the
celebrity boxing thing was happening
they were boxing each other up and that
was funny so they become the butt of the
joke I bet you and listen I guarantee
that money is [__] running dry
it is let's throw it to the water and
strike their [__] is dry as [__] so
they're doing extra [__] just to pop off
again so they can put money in their
bank account so they can live the
lifestyle that they are pretending to
have young content creators if you want
to be a content creator creation that
can last it has to be a well that you
could dip in over and over and over
again because if not this is the
lifestyle that you're going to live
you're going to end up kissing your
brother
Cloud chasing is so weird
it's so [__] odd and you've seen a
lot of people do it so you want to
follow it but I'll tell you this man
some of the saddest people I've ever met
and you might disagree you're an old
head you don't you don't know what the
[__] you just want to judge people all
the time suck my dick
I've built my whole career judging
people this is what I'm gonna do I just
don't want you all to go down that route
you have seen so many content creators
who have lasted three four five six
seven years because they created things
that they truly enjoyed here's the thing
man
when you start creating content or you
know what [__] that let's just let's
even let's even go broader than that
right
if you live and die by what other people
feel or think about the things that you
create this is where your career begins
and ends
think about what I just said
if you live and die by what people say
about the things that you create this is
where your career begins and it ends
yes as content creators when we create
something we put it out in The Ether for
people to judge that's exactly what it's
made for and so
when we create art it's supposed to be
scrutinized but is this art no it's
two brothers [__] face [__] each
other art I don't I don't really think
so
young clout Chasers out there clout
chasing content creators people get
tired of your [__] really fast and there
is no longevity in this and you tend to
spend all that money and you end up
having people just disappear and stop
watching your stuff really quickly some
people might say and I have heard this
that when you create content and fans
love what you do
it gives you motivation
right it gives you motivation because
you're receiving these like in you know
this endorphin of like hey I love your
[__] I love your [__] you're so cool oh
you're so morally just uh I follow and
love everything that you do and you feed
off that type of stuff but what happens
when that disappears even like say it
reduces by 10 15 and you've already tied
your art and your worth
based on what other people say
and my fans know this right
who have stuck with me for the past 11
12 years even
that I appreciate everything that they
do but they do not guide what I do do
you feel what I'm saying I appreciate
you supporting me right but you will not
change what I do just because of the
things that you say
if so then I would not have lasted in
this space as long as I have because
guess what if you feed off the positive
comments and you use that as fuel you
don't actually get to choose what goes
into your tank to fuel you up because
those comments can also be extremely
extremely negative and detrimental to
your health so if you're somebody out
there that constantly has to read
comments to make yourself feel better
what happens when those negative
comments come in you definitely don't
ignore it because you're hunting and
you're searching for it there's
absolutely no way when you're filtering
through 150 comments right
and you see these negative ass comments
that if you're somebody that lives and
dies by what other people say
about the things that you do that those
negative comments don't dig into you a
little bit and I'm saying this from
personal experience when I first started
YouTube dot let me tell you how dumb
like me Bart and Joe were right this is
something that we definitely shared in
common with each other that would be
like people back in the day that would
write comments and talk [__] and for us
we thought that social media was this
real face-to-face it was like the real
world right I mean social media is real
the sense that it exists but it's not
real in the sense that you could say
whatever you want without getting socked
in the [__] face but for us at the
time when YouTube just started we just
thought that oh people online also
behave like how they do in the real
world so when somebody would be like yo
your shit's not funny and you're a
little [__] like I used to write like
all right then where are you from let's
speed up if you want to scrap let's
[__] scrap now I don't know if I was
gonna win the fight but I wasn't gonna
let somebody talk to me like a [__] but
obviously I wouldn't get the response
that I wanted because it's so stupid I
still read comments right and as if you
guys notice on this page I'll like all
the comments even even a lot of the
negative stuff if it's within reason if
it's not within reason and it's just
somebody attacking me and being very
rude and disrespectful I just block them
because I don't want them in this world
but if it's somebody who just disagrees
with me and says stuff that they think
that my stuff is dumb and they give a
reason behind it I'll engage in that
I'll even thumbs up and like it even if
I disagree and you've seen that multiple
times but the type of comments that I
don't engage in that's negative like
I'll give you an example in the video
um not last week's but the week before
that I was doing it with uh Ryan right
and we were talking about in only like
10 or 15 about the things that I really
loved about JK news and how much love
and support that I got from it and you
know just a lot of misconceptions about
the company when it was going down I
wanted to clarify a few things even
further than I already did before and
somebody wrote this stupid ass [__]
comment and I deleted it and I blocked
them because you can go through their
page and they're just on everybody's
page talking [__] so that person gets
blocked right because they wrote this
stupid comment they go oh
Bart and Joe they were buying you food
taking you all you guys out on these
trips simply because it was a tax
write-off they're not doing it because
they care about you quit trying to lie
to your fans it's like listen here you
[__] made [__] dumb [__] [__]
if it was just supposed to be a tax
write-off don't you think there's a lot
of other ways that you could do it that
just benefits the owners themselves
instead of spending it on everybody else
you [__] idiot there's other
loopholes where you can just personally
gain from it you [__] hard suck my
[__] left nut
but God bless you and I hope you live a
very healthy life those people are the
ones that I block right because they're
not there for a conversation they're
just there to you know say stupid [__]
and try to get you mad which you know
kind of work which is why I block them I
don't want to have my mood based on what
other people say so for me when I read
comments I don't let it dictate what I
do just because the things are negative
I will either choose to block it or the
ones that are quote unquote negative but
are with within reason I'll engage and
still like it up because it's just a
different opinion you've seen it on
movie reviews you've seen it on current
topics and that's perfectly fine and
just to wrap it back up to my
conversation about what I'm talking
about with these island boys is that
they are such big clout Chasers and
they've never created content that made
them happy that they actually don't know
what to do they've only created content
because they wanted to see these numbers
rise and they have nothing to offer in
this [__] space there are so many
people like that and look look if you're
somebody who has nothing to offer and
this space but you just want to make
content just because you know you want
to copy other people's [__] that's
[__] fine I don't care we're only
talking about the island boys stop
taking everything so personally right
like I remember I tweeted or I was on
threads and I said uh couples comedy
this podcast is brought to you by Mint
mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
Wireless providers if we've learned
anything is that there's always a catch
so when I first heard that mid mobile
offers premium Wireless starting at just
15 bucks a month I thought was the catch
but after talking to them and using
their service it all made sense there
isn't one mid mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
Wireless services
online early they cut out the cost of
retail stores at past those sweet
savings directly to you let me tell you
something as a businessman I need two
phones one for the regular day-to-day
dailies and the rest for my business and
that's where my mint mobile comes in all
reliable and it saves me money I love it
so so much for anyone who hates their
phone bill mint mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month are
you insane to not take this deal you
spend more on a meal going out to eat
than that and that's 15 bucks mud
bitmobile gives you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint family start at two
lines to get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the
planche shipped to your door for free go
to bitmobile.com genius15 that's
mintmobile.com genius15 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com
couples comedy on social media is the
worst thing that happens since pranks
and I still stand by that [__] dude oh
my God couples comedy pranks is
literally the dumbest
recycled low-hanging fruit comedy of all
[__] time
you're this person you're the person
babe
um can I just tell you that uh we were
supposed to be honest in this
relationship so I think that you look
fat in this dress oh my God babe I can't
believe you said this babe I'm so angry
I'm so upset oh
go [__] yourself
if you are that person making that
content it you know beyond that not even
the people making if you watch that and
you wrote LOL this is so funny you are a
[__] idiot
yeah I said it you're a [__] idiot
apps how was that [__] funny
relatable
it really
is it really
hey babe check out that girl's ass bab
oh I can't believe you're checking that
girl's ass you never check out my ass
hey babe
I hate everything in this world this
world is evil and dark in the name of
Jesus I pray amen
Jesus
Christmas of all time why why do you do
this to yourself and other people if you
like those videos and you find it funny
please unfollow me
hey babe gunshots now
I wasn't I wasn't looking at her yeah it
really seems like you were I was looking
at the buns and then you pan down and
she has uh bread I'm so stupid
Jason Chen why listen there's a
reoccurring joke or a recurring joke on
this podcast and it's me like clowning
on Jason Chen Jason is a good friend of
mine I love him to death but this guy is
the worst
like his social media content makes me
want to throw my computer out my window
every day hey Bud he's the he's one of
the hey babe people
talk I love you so much bro but
sometimes when I see you I want to sock
you in your [__] face I guess it's so
[__] bad dude
this [__] goes on Tick Tock and
he sees what is popular and funny and he
looks at his girlfriend and goes we
should steal what they do like it's
this is the most Asian [__] you could
ever do and you would just have to be
Asian shout out to Jason Chen great
singer
I love it to death
all right I'm done
listen if you want to be a content
creator and if you if you're asking my
advice man just start by doing things
that you love because longevity is
important and you're not looking for the
three million views right you're looking
for the 30 000 people that watch and
follow you every day
those people are the ones that count
because they ride or die for you no
matter what and they really do get to
know you your online Persona very well I
don't care about the three or four
million views I care about the 30 or 40K
the 25k that come and watch this podcast
every week and support me and I'm there
for them and they're for me these are
the ones that [__] matter if I
created content for all new people all
the time I would lose my mind
in fact David you should try to gain new
fans you're right a hundred percent if I
want to be if I want to continue to be
successful in this space then of course
I should be creating content to grab new
people all the time but I will say this
though like new people will eventually
become the people that will ride or die
for me in the next four or five years
but the people who started with me when
I was the dude in Sacramento with not a
single [__] penny to my name watching
and sharing and supporting me since day
one we have a special [__] bot I do
not get to do what I do and continue to
be successful at what I do without this
type of support and they've been running
out since every [__] up they've
disagreed with the things that I've said
they've forgave they moved on and they
and they still continue to watch after
because they know that I'm going to make
mistakes all the time like these are the
ones that matter the most if you're
looking to be a content creator who
wants to be successful in this space for
a very long time don't look for the 3
million look for the thirty thousand
don't look for the thirty thousand look
for the three thousand
those are the people who are going to
support your products when you put it up
because they trust the hard work that
you put into it and even if you didn't
and you just had regular merchandise
they buy it because they want to support
you and watch you thrive because of the
times that you help them laugh the times
that you help them get away from pain
from their shitty house situation from
their shitty boyfriends their
girlfriends their parents whatever
watching your videos help them out so
they will support you you cater to
people who don't give a [__] about you
see how far that gets you see how long
it will last and it won't last at all I
have yet to see it even somebody like
Logan Paul right
he still creates consistent content
based on how much of a jackass he is and
those people who like likes his
jackassery they continue to follow him
he's brand consistent as [__] and he's
never really changed nobody looks at
Logan and says he's a [__] good
person and if you do you're [__]
weird even he knows he's not a good
person he just creates really good good
content I'm not saying I particularly
enjoy everything he puts out but in
terms of content and what he's doing
he's a good content creator you can't
knock him for that I mean look at the
stuff he's done in WWE
who the [__] else is gonna do that
who the [__] owls can like go over to
another form of entertainment and
[__] Smash and kill it in the way
that he does I respect the dude's hustle
I may not respect everything that he
does as a person obviously with the nft
[__] and the you know he stole Millions
from his fans [__] all that but from a
objective point of view in terms of him
being a content creator he has been
consistently creative in the way that he
always has been which is why he has
garnered such a large and strong fan
base
so I mean I guess his podcast turned out
to be something for people who want to
be young content creators stop looking
into other people's pockets to see what
they have and just focus on what you
have
some of my favorite content creators on
this space are the ones that have like
40 or 50 000 followers maybe even a
hundred thousand followers just because
they create good content I keep coming
back for more I I buy their products I
support them I talk about them 24
[__] seven it's amazing uh Gear
review
um there's a guy um Joshua Martin Senna
dailies you should check him out [__]
amazing tail Crawford I love his street
photography uh will be designed check
him out he recycles or upcycles uh
skateboards and does woodwork there's
Clara's wood shop you should follow her
on Instagram amazing stuff there are so
many micro influencers and just decent
content creators out there that don't
create cloud content and are consistent
and really good at what they [__] do
I love them David Nguyen my buddy he's
like a good he's becoming like solely a
really really good friend of mine we
just hung out in Hawaii I love his
content I love his backstory I love his
food I love his passion follow these
people and actually follow their
footsteps because watch how strong of a
fan they create and the content that
that really matters to people they are
doing an amazing job and these are the
people that actually influenced me and
have continued to keep me on this space
because when I watch them and I see
their original content I go dude I want
to still be in this space because I want
to create stuff and be a part of the
things that they do it's amazing so if
you want to be a content creator create
things to you that matter get the video
that'll blow up but sick but really look
deep inside you and see who you want to
be in the future in this space if not
you will not survive for a long time you
might even go crazy I've seen so many
content creators lose their [__] mind
in this space and it is so sad to see
because they were so talented but they
lived and died by what other people said
by their likes and their dislikes and so
when people stop watching their videos a
little bit when they got these huge
dislikes it ate them up inside so they
started doing crazier and crazier and
crazier things just for views
it's it's insane don't do that
be happy with the with the content and
the art that you create and it will
continue to give back to you throughout
your career I guarantee you I guarantee
it that's a David So stamp of guarantee
even my actor friends who do it because
they love acting they are the best at
their [__] craft you have seen so
many even if they did blow up they're
always like the whiny [__] that
always complain about oh I don't have
this opportunity I don't have this blah
blah blah blah blah you know why it's
because they never give a [__] about the
craft and everything every opportunity
they have a chance to [__] complain
they will [__] do it because they
love the attention they don't give a
[__] about the the hard work that it
takes to be an amazing actor and some of
the top people in this space who are
getting shine
who are getting recognized as actors are
the [__] worst they [__] suck
but of course that's only a small
percentage right but either way
I don't even know how long this podcast
is going
um but
let's wrap up this podcast here I
appreciate you all thank you for tuning
in I hope this helped a lot of young
creators who want to be in this space
which I didn't even think that this
podcast was going to be that
um I was just here to just talk about
the island boys [__] Jess among each
other disgusting [__] gross I can
never burn that image outside of my head
I didn't even
I didn't even know that this podcast was
going to be about any of this stuff but
I guess I always have to end it on some
type of positive note because originally
it was just me roasting the crackhead
boys but hey if you have any questions
about content creation or what you want
to do on the space or how you want to be
successful in your own way as a content
creator uh ask questions in the comments
below if you're listening to this on on
the audio side come to the YouTube side
and then ask these questions and maybe
I'll answer it on another podcast but
love you all appreciate you so much
thank you for tuning in
um and I'll see you all next time genius
brain every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll be
back to our regular program in the new
podcast Studio next week once again I'm
moving I'm [__] busy but we're gonna
get it done love you all very much I'll
see you all next time
um my balls are not hairy anymore
because I shaped it yesterday love you
bye